[Musica]
[Applauso]
vorrei chiedervi di alzarvi ma fatelo
solo se mi conoscete magari perché siamo
amici parenti o forse in un qualche
momento della nostra vita capitato di
incontrarci e di interagire in qualche
modo potreste essere stati ad esempio
nei professori compagni di classe
compagni di pallone allenatori
alzatevi anche se siamo in contatto in
qualche social network come facebook
twitter linkedin e magari lì ci è
capitato di scambiarci qualche commento
qualche messaggio ecco voi che vi siete
alzati ora anche quelli più in fondo
avete in realtà tutti una stessa
distanza da ma è quella distanza è un
grado di separazione
ma che cosa vuol dire beh secondo la
scienza delle reti ovvero quella
disciplina che unisce matematica
statistica probabilità fisica per
studiare le strutture di connessione che
crediamo ogni giorno un grado di
separazione vuol dire che tra me e voi
esiste un unico ponte immaginario che ci
consente di interagire ogni qualvolta lo
vogliamo e senza alcun tipo di
intermediari invece è seduto avrà più
gradi di separazione da man ad esempio
vorrei appunto chiedere a chi al momento
è seduto di alzarsi se per gli stessi
motivi che ho elencato in precedenza
conosce almeno una delle persone che al
momento sono in piedi
fatelo
ecco voi che vi siete alzati ora avete
fece due gradi di separazione da ma ci
sono cioè due ponti immaginari che
dovremo attraversare per entrare in
relazione
prevedete sto pian piano creando una
nuova idea di distanza è una distanza
nascosta quasi impercettibile che non si
misura in chilometri metri ore di volo
ma tramite il numero di ponti immaginari
che dovremo attraversare per entrare in
relazione
se ad esempio volessi sapere chi vista
da mettere gradi di separazione non
dovrai far altro che chiedere di alzarsi
a chi al momento si trova in piedi ma
conosce almeno una delle persone che al
momento sono alzate fatelo per favore
ancora guardatevi un po attorno
siete già quasi tutti in piedi questo
non mi stupisce anzi vi dirò di più se
in questa stanza ci fosse stata tutta la
popolazione del mondo sono circa 7
miliardi e 600 milioni di persone e io
avessi ripetuto questo esperimento
solamente altre tre volte si sarebbero
alzati quasi tutti in piedi
si chiama teoria dei sei gradi di
separazione sostanzialmente ci dice che
chiunque al mondo ovunque li sia
dovunque sia nato può essere messo in
contatto con qualsiasi altra persona
tramite una sequenza fatta da non più di
sei punti relazionali esisterà cioè
quasi sicuramente un amico dell'amico
dell'amico dell'amico di un vostro amico
che vi può mettere in contatto con
chiunque vogliate sulla faccia della
terra
ora so già che non ci credete tutti
quindi proviamo a fare un veloce conto
mentre vi rivedete
provate a pensare
che io abbia 45 amici non sono molti
generalmente abbiamo ben di più e
provate a pensare che ora ognuno di
questi 45 amici ne abbia a sua volta
altri 45 diversi tra loro e provate a
ripetere questo esperimento per altre
quattro volte
arriverete a contare 45 elevato alla sei
persone sono circa 8 miliardi e 303
milioni di persone ben di più di quelle
ore sulla faccia della terra è un numero
enorme un numero che per come nasce di
fatto si colloca tutti molto più vicini
è una sorta di small world così che
viene chiamato nella teoria delle reti
c'è un piccolo mondo che magari farà
sentire alcuni di voi un po meno soli
altri forse un po troppo pressi quello
che ha trasmesso a ma è stato invece un
enorme fascino per la matematica e la
geometria che questo risultato nasconde
se ci pensate è una geometria che crea
una nuova realtà parallela in cui le
nostre distanze non sono più misurate in
m km ore di volo ma tramite il numero di
ponti relazionali dei gradi di
separazione che dovremo attraversare per
entrare in contatto
in realtà è proprio in questo spazio che
si muove la maggior parte della vostra
vita
proviamo a ragionarci qual è oggi
l'unico vincolo che ci impedisce di
interagire voi al momento avete in tasca
tutti di sicuro un oggetto il vostro
smartphone
il quale contiene moltissime
applicazioni whatsapp messenger skype
chiamate le email per le quali vi
consentono di interagire con chiunque
vogliate sulla faccia della terra
i millesimi di secondo a patto che a
patto che la distanza tra voi e questa
persona sia un grado di separazione
cioè se ci pensate oggi l'unico vincolo
che ci impedisce di interagire in realtà
il più banale il più semplice però anche
io direi più romantico possibile cioè
quello del conoscerci o meno questo vale
anche per me sebbene
mi trovi qui a pochi metri da voi in
realtà non vi conosco tutti anzi alcuni
di voi non li conosco affatto o con
altri o molti gradi di separazione
questo significa che finora le nostre
vite non si sono ancora intersecate
potrebbero farlo tramite i contatti che
abbiamo in comune ma potrebbero anche
non farlo mai
in questo caso continueremo a viaggiare
su due binari paralleli e per la storia
della mia vita sebbene ora voi vi
troviate pochi metri da me ne sareste un
po come l'australia nello spazio delle
relazioni sarà esserci estremamente
lontani o invece molti amici in
inghilterra in spagna brasile stati
uniti
loro ora si trovano a migliaia di
chilometri da ma tuttavia la loro storia
la loro vita influenza continuamente la
mia un po come se in questo spazio
nascosto di relazioni noi fossimo in
realtà estremamente vicini
ecco che ora le distanze che separano me
quel cerchio rosso che vedete da voi che
siete i cerchi azzurri ed ai miei amici
cerchi verdi non rappresentano la
geometria della mia vita non sono anzi
una rappresentazione estremamente
instabile di questa geometria quello che
in realtà vorrei fare se mi venisse
concesso di muovermi non senza vincoli
in questo spazio nascosto di relazioni
sarebbe allontanarmi da chi tra voi non
conosco un po come se fossimo tutti
delle particelle elettriche con la
stessa carica che si avvicina the nello
spazio e non connesse tendono
respingersi quello che invece vorrei
fare avvicinarmi man mano ai miei amici
con i quali sono connesso come se quelle
connessioni fossero in realtà delle
molle che ci avvicinano nello spazio
qualora fossimo lontani e vorrei
continuare a muovermi libero in questo
spazio fin tanto che queste forze di
attrazione repulsione non tenderanno ad
annullarsi creando così un nuovo una
nuova dimensione in cui le mie nuove
posizioni saranno coerenti non più con
le distanze fisiche ma con i gradi di
separazione
ora quello
e vi ho raccontato in realtà è proprio
un algoritmo che utilizziamo in
statistica per proiettare le tante reti
che oggi osserviamo in un nuovo sistema
di coordinate capace di darci nuove
informazioni di informazioni nascoste
riguardo alla rete ora probabilmente
molti di voi troveranno questo metodo
dello spazio che genera estremamente
astratto
in realtà io ho una buona notizia per
voi e cioè che senza accorgervene voi
ragionate in questo spazio di relazioni
molte più volte rispetto a quanto
pensate provate a pensare a quando
prenotate un volo aereo
una delle prime cose che fate dopo aver
guardato il costo del biglietto è quello
di vedere quanti sono gli scali che
separano il vostro aeroporto di partenza
da quello di arrivo per poi generalmente
scegliere il volo con meno scali
possibile ecco voi quando fate questa
decisione in realtà non state più
ragionando nello spazio fisico che
separa gli aeroporti tramite km alle ore
di volo stato in realtà ragionando nello
spazio nascosto nelle connessioni in cui
una distanza tra i due aeroporti non è
più data dai chilometri che li separano
quanto invece dai gradi di separazione
cioè dagli scali che li dividono è lo
spazio che partendo da questa immagine
che alle vere posizioni dagli aeroporti
si sta creando in questo momento come
vedete sembra una sorta di deriva dei
continenti che partendo dalla geometria
vera dello spazio fisico raggiunge una
nuova geometria un nuovo sistema di
coordinate coerenti con i gradi di
separazione italia aeroporti guardate
come gli aeroporti più importanti sono
quelli più grossi aggiungano man mano il
centro di gravità di questo nuovo mondo
sono infatti quelli con il maggior
numero di voli quindi più importanti nel
garantire la connessione all'interno del
questa rete viceversa gli aeroporti più
piccoli con separati da più gradi di
separazione si muovono lentamente verso
la periferia
come vedete è una sorta di deriva dei
continenti che ora crea un nuovo mondo
un mondo a triangolo in cui l'america si
avvicina man mano all'asia sono infatti
anche esse connesse davoli tramite
l'oceano pacifico e in cui l'africa si
colloca tra europa ed asia
ed è in questo spazio non è il
planisfero che voi ragionate quando
scegliete un volo da ieri in base agli
scali
ora se questo video vi affascina ma
quando l'ho creato affascinato molto
sono felice per voi
in realtà a me che sono uno scienziato
dei dati e mi piace plasmarli e
manipolarli per trasformare informazioni
in conoscenza
quello che in questo video non mi basta
quello che veramente mi affascina quando
i nuovi spazi nuovi sistemi di
coordinate a cui siamo arrivati tramite
l'analisi dei dati di connessione
d'un tratto svelano una nuova storia una
storia nascosta che magari potevamo
utilizzare per migliorare le nostre
una di queste alla storia legata a
questa rete questa è una rete di persone
apparentemente comuni che magari avesse
potuto trovare sparse in modo casuale in
una qualche piazza senza alcun tipo di
geometria tuttavia nello spazio nascosto
delle connessioni secondo questo sistema
di molle particelle queste persone
avrebbero iniziato pian piano a muoverci
avvicinandosi a coloro alle quali sono
connesse ed allontanandosi da coloro
alle quali sono meno connesse come
vedete nello spazio nascosto delle
relazioni in questo nuovo sistema di
coordinate ora notiamo una nuova storia
è una storia di tre gruppi come li
vedete due più piccoli ed uno più grande
vengono chiamate comunità nella teoria
delle reti con le due più piccole che
passi uniscono quasi sempre alla rete
principale passando per quel grosso
cerchio rosso
ecco la sua dimensione così come quella
delle altre persone sono anche se state
costruite tramite metodi statistici
volti a valutare l'importanza di
ciascuna di quelle persone nel garantire
la coesione e la trasmissione di
informazione all'interno della rete
ad esempio se questa fosse stata una
rete di contatti fisici tra persone e a
me venisse chiesto di manipolarla per
fare in modo che ad esempio una certa
malattia infettiva non si diffonda
facilmente attraverso la rete
una delle prime cose che avrei fatto
sarebbe stato di prelevare quel grosso
cerchio rosso e in quel modo avrei quasi
spezzato la rete in due facendo sì che
la malattia infettiva fosse isolata
sulla coda comunità in cui è nata avrei
fatto lo stesso nella triste storia
legata a questa rete
questa è una rete che ha influenzato
tutte le nostre quel grosso cerchio
rosso infatti si chiama mohamed atta
ed è uno dei più noti terroristi che
assieme agli altri che vedete colorati
in rosso si schiantò sulla torre nord
del world trade center a new york 11
settembre del 2001
gli altri cerchi colorati sono invece
gli attentatori che si schiantarono
negli altri aerei
viceversa quelli grigi sono tutti i
terroristi che fornirono un qualche tipo
di supporto in termini di denaro
informazioni addestramento aereo ai vari
attentatori questa è la loro rete
terroristica che venne pubblicata alcuni
giorni dopo i vari giornali e che fu
parzialmente ricostruita da alcuni
ricercatori come vi dicevo sono
connessioni date da intercettazioni
ambientali scambi di denaro
addestramento aereo alcune delle quali
erano già disponibili prima di quella
drammatica giornata
tuttavia come vedete
la drammatica giornata era già
parzialmente scritta nelle coordinate di
questa rete che di fatto ci sta dicendo
di prelevare mohammed atta non fare in
modo di far mancare agli attentatori
tutte le informazioni denaro che
proveniva dagli altri ecco non so come
sarebbe andata
quello che è di certo so è che oggi
abbiamo le armi per combattere questo
tipo di reti non sono bombe
sono caccia matematica statistica
analisi dei dati probabilità conoscenze
in generale è un ultima rete è la rete
che per me è la più importante di tutti
ma anche la più misteriosa
il vostro cervello
rim partito
di fibre nervose che connette le nostre
diverse regioni cerebrali e consente
all'informazione di passare tra queste
ecco raccogliere questo tipo di dati è
oggi diventato sempre più facile grazie
ai molti sviluppi che abbiano che
abbiamo fatto in ambito di risonanza
magnetica e questo di fatto aperto un
nuovo universo ma dentro di noi è un
universo che per me è fatto di numeri
connessioni forme che si evolvono e
plasmano di fatto il nostro carattere e
la nostra personalità
e sebbene la rete cerebrale nelle vedete
un esempio in questo video rispetti
geometrie proprietà comuni in realtà
ogni singolo spazio relazionale dietro
ciascuno dei vostri cervelli a qualcosa
di diverso
è una sorta di variabilità matematica
che vi rende le persone che siete a me
piace setacciare questa variabilità
viabilità matematica per scoprire la
firma e strutture comuni e la firma
della rete in molte degli dei fenomeni
che oggi non conosciamo come parkinson
alzheimer memoria intelligenza
apprendimento ad esempio in una recente
ricerca abbiamo dimostrato come la
chiave della creatività non sia legata
al vecchio mito dell'emisfero destro
sinistro per quanto invece alla capacità
di creare molte connessioni tra i due
emisferi
in questo modo nelle persone creative le
regioni cerebrali saranno molto più
vicine nello spazio delle connessioni
rispetto a quanto non lo siano nello
spazio fisico
è con questo tipo di analisi e con altre
che spero apriremo le porte verso nuovi
sviluppi e nero scoperti nuovi misteri
dietro nostro cervello
magari aprendo anche le porte per
ulteriori sviluppi nell'intelligenza
artificiale
per quanto mi riguarda io ho un'unica
certezza al momento è che quanto meno ad
oggi esiste un unico supercomputer che
per capacità di apprendimento abilità
nell'elaborare l'informazione quando
anche questa sconosciuta e tempi di
reazione batte qualsiasi altro super
computer presente oggi sulla faccia
della terra
secondo alcune analisi ci vogliono
mediamente
nove mesi per progettarlo poi 18 anni
per insegnargli ad apprendere e
mediamente 79 per ucciderlo
e da ciascuno di voi è l'essere umano e
vediamo di non sprecarlo
[Applauso]